RONALD SMITH: Well, today
we're going to talk
about mixing and dilution.
When you add something to
the atmosphere, gases or
particles, what happens to it?
How does it mix in?
To what degree does
it get diluted?
This is a subject that has
applications to human-induced
air pollution, but also to
a large number of natural
processes in the atmosphere.
So it's really a set of quite
fundamental ideas.
And I could be thinking about
either small particles or
gases added to the atmosphere.
Basically, something that's
going to move with the air and
mix in, in a way.
If the particles are large
enough, of course, they might
gravitationally fall
out after awhile.
And that effect would not be
included in the calculations
I'm doing here.
So I'm assuming the particles
are small or it's a gas so
that it will just move along
with the air itself.
So the easiest case--
maybe it's a little bit,
unnatural, but not so much
--is that you're in a confined
valley and you know the
dimensions of the valley--
horizontal dimensions of the
valley, and the valley is
capped, in some way.
I've written here that it's
capped by an inversion.
Now, I'll give a more careful
and physical interpretation of
inversion later on, but an
inversion is defined as a
layer of air in which
the temperature
increases with height.
And for reasons that are not at
all clear, from what I've
just said, but will become
clear, it's very difficult for
mixing to occur across
an inversion.
An inversion tends to act
almost like a rigid lid.
It holds air and pollutants
below it or in any way,
prevents it from crossing.
In this case, it traps these
pollutants below the inversion.
So leaving that as only
partially defined concept for
a moment, we'll know then the
volume of the air into which
the pollution from my little
power plant here has reached.
The volume into which the
substance has mixed is then
the product of the two
horizontal dimensions, L1 and
L2, and the depth of the layer,
that's the depth up to
the inversion.
The mass of the air into which
the pollutant has mixed is
just the product of the air
density and that volume.
And that's going to have units
of kilograms. So here comes a
very simple example.
Let's that over some period of
time we put in 40 metric tons
of a pollutant.
Maybe it's small particles,
for example, or a gas.
A metric ton, you recall, is a
thousand kilograms. So I've
written that in SI units as 40
times 10 to the 3 kilograms.
That's the amount of pollutant
we've put in.
That's quite a bit, but it
depends on the problem we're
working on.
Let's say that the horizontal
dimensions of the valley are
10 kilometers in one dimension
and 10 kilometers in the other
dimension and that
the depth to the
inversion is one kilometer.
So then the concentration of the
pollutant is going to be
the mass of the pollutant
divided by the mass of the air
into which it has mixed.
I didn't put that definition up
here, but be sure you get
that in your notes.
We're defining concentration in
this case as a mass ratio.
The mass of pollutant that
you've added to the atmosphere
divided by the mass of the air
into which it has mixed.
So here's the formula then.
There's the mass of pollutant
that we added, 40 times 10 to
the three kilograms, and here's
the mass of the air
into which it mixed, it's the
air density multiplied times
the volume of the air--
L1 L2 times D. So it's 10
kilometers expressed in
meters, 10 kilometers again,
and one kilometer
expressed in meters.
You work all that out, you
get 0.4 times 10 to the 6
kilograms per kilogram.
You could cancel it out and
say it has no units.
That's fine.
Or you could leave it as
kilograms per kilogram, just
to remind you what it is.
It's a kilogram of pollutant
mixed into a certain number of
kilograms of the air into
which you mixed it.
So since this is 10 to the minus
6 and it's a mass ratio,
I could also write this
as 0.4 ppmm, parts
per million by mass.
The per million, the pm there,
refers to the 10
to the minus 6.
And the last m there
refers to the fact
that it's a mass ratio.
Question?
Yes.
STUDENT: Why is it kilograms
of pollutant?
PROFESSOR: Well, because I've
got the kilograms
here, but it's kilograms of
pollutant divided by the
kilograms of air into which
it's been mixed.
STUDENT: So they don't
cancel out?
PROFESSOR: They could.
That's what I mentioned.
You could cancel that out.
I wouldn't mind it at
all if you did.
But I sometimes like to keep it
there just to remind myself
of what that definition is.
Either way would be fine.
It'd be perfectly fine
to cancel that out.
Normally, concentration is
considered to be a quantity
that has no units.
But sometimes I like to keep it
there just as a reminder.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Why are the tens raised
to the fourth power?
Oh, it's meters.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Where are you
looking?
STUDENT: The concentration
calculation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, that's right.
So this was 10 kilometers.
And a kilometer is
a 1,000 meters.
So the 10 times the 3 gives 4,
10 to the fourth meters.
Yeah.
STUDENT: What is L1
and L2 again?
PROFESSOR: The horizontal
dimensions of the valley.
STUDENT: Oh, so the area.
PROFESSOR: Well the
product is the area of the
valley, but the L1 is the
dimension in one direction, L2
is the dimension in the
other direction.
If you want to know the base
area of the valley,
that's L1 times L2.
Other questions?
Yes?
STUDENT: Where did you
get 10 to the third?
PROFESSOR: 10 to the third?
STUDENT: It's the mass of the
air below the inversion?
PROFESSOR: Well the
mass of the air below the
inversion is what's in
the denominator here.
It's the density of the air
times the volume of the air
and the volume was given by that
product, which you see
written out here.
Yeah.
It's good to get this one really
clear, because the next
one is even tougher.
So any other questions
on this one?
OK.
So now we move to case two,
which is unconfined mixing.
We don't have this predetermined
valley in a nice
inversion in which
we know things
are going to be trapped.
We know how much pollutant
we're putting in--
I'm going to use the same value
as I did here --but we
don't know into what volume
will it be mixed.
But we're going to assume that
there's a certain amount of
turbulence in this atmosphere.
The air is kind of mixing and
spinning and moving around a
little bit.
And we're going to define
something called the
dispersion coefficient which
will help us decide how fast
that added material will diffuse
or will disperse into
the atmosphere.
I'll call it capital K and it
has units of meters squared
per second.
And you can estimate a magnitude
for that quantity in
the following way.
You can take a typical
turbulent velocity--
let's say there are eddies in
this room that are turning
over and that air speed has a
certain value, let's say one
meter per second.
And a typical eddy size, maybe
the eddies are filling the
space between the floor
and the ceiling,
that's about four meters.
So if that were the case, if
the typical speed were one
meter per second, and the eddy
size were four meters, that
would give a dispersion
coefficient of four meters
squared per second.
It's simply that product.
See, that'll give you
the right units.
That has meters per second.
This has meters.
And so that's going to give
meters squared per second,
when you take that product.
So this is sometimes very
difficult to determine, what
that dispersion coefficient is
going to be for a particular
atmospheric application.
But you can get a rough
estimate, if you can estimate
the size of the eddies and the
speed at which those eddies
are turning over in this
turbulent atmosphere.
Let's say somehow we
know what that is.
Then how fast will that mix
things into the atmosphere?
If I have a point source sitting
on the ground, one
direction is as good as
any other direction.
It's going to mix to the left,
to the right, and up equally
fast. So it's going to produce
a kind of hemisphere of
pollutant, a half sphere that's
growing in time as that
material diffuses outward
and upward.
And the radius of that
hemisphere is given by this
formula, the square root of
the dispersion coefficient
times time.
So the longer you wait, the
larger that hemisphere will
be, and of course, the more
dilute will be the pollutant
because you've put a fixed
amount of pollutant in, unless
you're continuing to add it.
I'm assuming, the problem I'm
going to work out here, you
put in just a fixed amount of
pollutant and then gradually
you watch it dilute itself as
it mixes into a larger and
larger part of the atmosphere.
So what does that say?
It goes as a square
root of time.
That function, the square root
function, increases rapidly at
first and then more
slowly later on.
And that is the nature of
turbulent dispersion.
Rapidly at first and then more
slowly later in time.
And you may have had
that experience.
If you burn something in the
kitchen and you're right
there, you smell it
very quickly.
A couple of meters away, it
takes a lot longer to get
there and even further away even
longer, but not linearly.
It actually gets slower
and slower and slower.
The advance of that burned smell
moves slower and slower
as time progresses.
So rapidly at first and then
more slowly later on describes
how things disperse away
from their source.
So let's carry out this
example then.
Let's say the dispersion
coefficient on this day is a
100 meters squared per second
and that the time we're going
to wait after the pollutant
was suddenly
put in is 10 minutes.
Well, that's 600 seconds.
So the first thing is to compute
the radius of that
hemisphere that contains
the pollutant.
It's the square root
of 100 times 600.
And that's about 245 meters.
By the way, check the
units on this.
Is this going to give
you a length?
How can that be?
Well, if I multiply this times
the time, the seconds are
going to cancel out.
I'm going to have
meters squared
inside the square root.
Taking the square root, that
gives me units of meters.
And that's just what I need to
be physically consistent with
this quantity, R, which is the
radius of the hemisphere.
So these units work
out nicely.
So the radius of that's going
to be 245 meters.
We want to know the volume or
the mass of the air into which
the pollutant has spread.
So I've written here the formula
for the air mass.
It's the density of the air,
rho, times the volume of half
of a sphere.
You may recall the formula for
the volume of a sphere is 4/3
pi r cubed.
Well, I've taken half of that,
because this is a hemisphere.
It's half of a sphere.
So it's 2/3 pi r cubed.
And I put the density in front,
so I get the mass of
the air and it's 3.7 times 10
to the 7 kilograms. So what
have I done?
I'm going to use the
same source here.
I've mixed in 40 times 10 to
the third kilograms of
pollutant into 3.7 times 10 to
the seventh kilograms of air.
So the concentration is given
by that ratio and it's 1.1
times 10 to the minus 3.
Again, you could cancel that out
or you could say kilograms
per kilogram.
Kilogram of pollutant
per kilogram of air.
Question?
Yes.
STUDENT: So you don't know the
radius of the hemisphere
unless you know the dispersion
coefficient
and the time which--?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
It's right.
So unlike the valley case, where
we kind of knew from the
initial dimensions of the
system, how big or how much
the dilution will be, here we
have to estimate it based on
the dispersion coefficient
and the time that's left.
Obviously, for longer times,
that's going to continue to
grow and this concentration
is going to get less
and less and less.
We haven't removed any
pollutant, but we've diluted
it into a larger and larger
amount of air.
Yes?
STUDENT: And so the
air density is not
affected by the pollutant?
PROFESSOR: No.
I'm assuming that this is a
small amount of pollutant
relative to the air.
And so no.
It doesn't change
the air density.
It just mixes in with the air.
Yeah.
Was there another question?
Yes.
STUDENT: So this only tells
you overall concentration
rather than concentration within
the different smaller
hemispheres it could go to?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
that's a very good question.
The question is this only tells
you what's going on
generally within that sphere.
It doesn't give you details of
what's inside the sphere.
And of course, the model that
I've described here is not
precisely true.
If I were to plot concentration
across this
distance, it would be
very small outside.
It would begin to rise smoothly,
probably would be at
maximum somewhere in
the middle, and
then decrease again.
Whereas what I've indicated to
you, which is a little bit
off, is if there would be
zero outside and uniform
concentration inside and then
zero again outside.
And that's not exactly true.
So your vision of it
is actually more
accurate than mine.
It'd be more of a continuous
distribution, large closer to
the source, smaller
further away.
But this is an easy-to-compute
estimate of what those
concentrations would be.
You would not have a sharp
boundary here with this
concentration inside
and zero outside.
It wouldn't be like that,
there'd be more of a gradual
transition.
So this is kind of an
approximation to the real
condition.
That's an excellent question.
Other questions on this?
So there would be our
concentration
after time, 600 seconds.
You could redo the computation
for a later time and you'd get
a larger value in the
denominator and therefore, a
smaller value of
concentration.
That's the way dilution works.
Anything else on this?
OK.
Now we're going to add another
element of complexity here.
For case three, we're
going to add a wind.
So there's a wind blowing
in this system.
So it's unconfined, no
valley walls, but now
there's a wind blowing.
So I've drawn some little
cartoons here.
There is the source.
Maybe it's a-- what I'm
envisioning here is not just
an instantaneous release of
pollutant, like I was in case
one and case two, but here I'm
envisioning a steady state
source of pollution, like a
power plant that's putting out
a certain amount of smoke from
the stack per unit time
continuously.
If I had a side view of that,
and the wind was blowing from
left to right, I would find
that pollutant would be
confined in a kind of--
we call this a plume, a plume
of pollutant, moving
downstream, getting deeper the
further it goes downstream due
to the turbulent mixing.
If I had a top-view of
that same situation--
here's the top-view -there's the
power plant, there's the
source, the wind is from
left to right.
Now we see that plume is
spreading in the horizontal
dimensions as well, again
by turbulent mixing and
dispersion.
And if I was to slice this here
or here and look at it
along the direction of the
wind, at any particular
distance downstream, x, it would
look like half a circle.
And the radius of that circle
will be larger the further
downwind that I go, because
dispersion is enlarging that
plume the further we get
from the source.
So how are we going to
work this one out?
Again, it's just a matter of
computing dilution, but now
this is a steady-state pollution
and we're going to
have to take into account the
effect of wind moving that
material downwind.
So I wanted to define a transit
time, the time it
takes the air to go from the
pollutant source to whatever x
location we're interested in.
Maybe your house is five
kilometers downwind of the
power plant.
Well then, x is going to
be five kilometers.
And the time it takes the air to
get from the power plant to
your house is going to be x
divided by the wind speed.
Wind speed is capital
U in this case.
Notice that'll have the right
units, distance over a
distance per time.
That's going to work out
to have units of time.
The radius of this plume is
given by the same formula we
had earlier, except now it's
this transit time we put in to
that formula.
It's a steady-state situation,
so it's not changing in time,
but yet there is this transit
time that plays the role of
time in the original problem.
So I'll put in x over t into
this formula and I get kx over
u square root for this quantity,
r, that you see in
each of these three diagrams.
Question, yes.
STUDENT: What is U?
PROFESSOR: U is the
wind speed, typically in
meters per second.
Now, by the way, the
cross-sectional area of this
plume, if I were to slice
across like this,
it is half a circle--
and you know the area of the
circle is pi r squared --and
so the plume cross-sectional
area is pi r squared divided
by two, because it's
half a circle.
Now here comes probably the
trickiest part of the
derivation.
I'm going to assume that I know
the source strength and
that's how much pollutant is
being added to the air per
unit time by the power plant.
That might have units, for
example, of kilograms per
second, kilograms of smoke,
let's say, being added to the
atmosphere every second.
Well, in a steady state, the
amount of pollutant being
added at the source must be the
same amount that's being
carried away by the wind.
And so by equating those two, I
can derive a formula for the
concentration.
So this is the key step, I'm
going to equate the rate at
which pollutant's being added
to the rate at which it's
being carried away
by the wind.
So on the left-hand side is a
rate which it's being added,
this is the rate at
which it's being
carried away by the wind.
Let me go through this
right-hand side.
That's the air density, that's
wind speed, that's the
cross-sectional area
of the plume.
And so that product by itself,
those three things together,
is the amount of air per unit
time passing a way within the
plume-- being carried downwind
by the wind.
And I just have to multiply that
times the concentration
to convert that from an
air mass flux to a
pollutant air mass flux.
So then solving this formula
for concentration, I get 2
times the source, I've plugged
this in there as well, 2 times
the source, divided by the
density of the air, divided by
pi times k times x.
And you're going to want to
leave an inch or two in your
notes to check the units
on this as well.
For example, the units on the
concentration, we expect if
previous calculations are
right, it'll be either
kilograms per kilogram, if
you prefer, or it'll
have no units at all.
And so all the units over
here should cancel out.
And leave an inch or two of your
notes to deal with that.
One very interesting thing is
that the velocity of the wind
canceled out.
How did that happen?
I had it here because the rate
at which material is being
blown downwind is going to be
proportional to the wind speed.
But you see the radius here,
well the area, depends on r,
and r depends on U underneath.
So when you square the radius,
you get a U underneath, which
cancels that out.
So the width of the plume will
change with the wind speed,
but not the concentration
within the plume.
And when you do--
you're going to do a couple of
examples like this in your
next problem set.
When you're doing that, you
might spend a few minutes
puzzling over what was the
role of the wind speed.
The wind speed is very important
in this problem, but
in that particular formula,
it is canceled out.
And so you should try to resolve
that little dilemma--
how, if the wind speed is
important, how did it cancel
out in that particular
formula.
So think a bit about how
that would work.
Any questions on this?
Yes.
STUDENT: What is A?
PROFESSOR: A is the--
is this thing, the
cross-sectional area of the
plume, pi r squared over 2.
Yes.
STUDENT: What is the x in
the equation over there?
PROFESSOR: X is
the distance between the
source of the pollutant and the
location of interest: your
house or the school yard, where
the kids are playing, or
whatever it is that you're
interested in finding out what
the concentration is.
It's the distance away from
the pollutant source.
Now obviously, if the wind is
from the west and you're
living down here somewhere, that
plume is not going to hit
you at all.
So this calculation is
irrelevant for you.
So the wind direction comes into
this in a very important
way also, I haven't mentioned
that up until now, but it's
probably quite obvious that the
wind direction is a key
player in this.
It's only if the wind is blowing
generally in the
direction from the source to
your location that this
calculation becomes relevant.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Does the plume
get wider as you go
farther away from it?
So if you live south of
it, far enough away--
PROFESSOR: That's true.
That's what I've sketched.
This is a top view.
It is getting wider, fast at
first, and then slower.
But it never stops widening,
it keeps getting wider and
wider and wider the further
you are downwind.
So that's true.
If you lived a great distance
downwind, but not in the
exactly in the wind direction,
you might still get the
pollutant, because
the pollution
will widen the plume.
So keep track of that when you
do these calculations.
Yes.
STUDENT: What does
source represent
in that final equation?
PROFESSOR: Source
would be the rate at which
pollutant is being added to the
atmosphere at the power
plant, let's say.
It could be in units of
kilograms per second.
But if it's particles, it
could be the number of
particles per second
that's being added.
And then your concentration
would have to be in the
appropriate--
by the way, that's the curve
ball I've given you the
problem set.
I think I gave you a problem in
which the source was quoted
as a number of particles
per second.
And so the concentration then
was in units of particles per
cubic meter, rather than
kilograms per cubic meter.
So just be wary, you have
to have consistent
units when you do this.
OK, now we're going to leave
that there and move on to
another aspect of mixing which
is very important also.
And that's the role of the
temperature lapse rate.
So I called this section lapse
rate and buoyancy effects.
First of all, I want to define
what I mean by the lapse rate.
Lapse rate is the rate
of change of
temperature with height.
If you launch a balloon and get
that data back, you can
measure the values of
temperature with height and
you can define the lapse rate.
It has units typically of
degrees Celsius per meter or
perhaps you would want to use
degrees Celsius per kilometer.
It's basically how fast is the
temperature change in the
atmosphere as you
go up and down.
Typically, in the troposphere,
you remember, it gets colder
as you go up.
And an average value--
I'm using lower gamma for this
--typical lapse rate for the
troposphere is about 6.5 degrees
Celsius per kilometer.
On average, every kilometer
you go up, it
cools about 6.5 degrees.
But don't take that
too literally.
That's just an average.
Sometimes it's very different
than that,
sometimes it's even positive.
For example, in an inversion--
remember how I defined
an inversion?
An inversion was a layer
where the temperature
increases with height.
Well, that would mean a positive
lapse rate, instead
of a negative one.
So for some layers-- and then in
the stratosphere, remember
you have a positive lapse rate,
the temperature gets
warmer as you go up.
The other really important
quantity is a more of a
theoretical one, but it's
equally important.
It's the adiabatic lapse rate.
This is the lapse rate
that a parcel of air
experiences when it rises.
Why would the temperature
of an air parcel
change when it rises?
Well, it's pretty--
it's fairly straightforward.
When you take an air parcel of a
certain volume and lift it--
you know the pressure decreases
as you go up, so
when you lift a parcel
up, it's going to
expand a little bit.
You lift it further, it's going
to expand still more.
And when air expands, it does
work on its environment by
pressing out and expanding.
It decreases the amount of
energy stored in the parcel
because it's done work
on the environment.
And its temperature drops.
It's called adiabatic expansion
or adiabatic cooling.
The word adiabatic here
means without adding
or subtracting heat.
And you may wonder, how can I
change the temperature without
adding heat?
The point is I'm changing the
temperature by having that
parcel do work on its
environment, not by adding
heat from some energy source.
It's purely a mechanical process
of expanding the air
and watching it cool because of
that adiabatic expansion.
That's quite a powerful
effect, as you'll
see in just a moment.
So the adiabatic lapse rate is
defined as a rate of cooling
as an air parcel rises.
It is a reversible phenomenon,
so if a parcel sinks back down
in the atmosphere, it will
compress and its temperature
will increase at
the same rate.
I'll use capital gamma
for this quantity,
adiabatic lapse rate.
It can be computed as a ratio of
the acceleration of gravity
to the heat capacity
of the air.
If this were a course on
thermodynamics, I would derive
that for you.
For the earth, and our
atmosphere made of air, the
value is about minus 9.3
times [correction: 9.8]
10 to the minus 3 degrees
Celsius per meter or
expressing that in kilometers,
it's about minus 9.8 degrees
Celsius per kilometer.
Question.
STUDENT: What's the
denominator again?
PROFESSOR: The heat capacity of
constant
pressure for air.
You could look it up in a table
of physical constants.
You can Google it.
Its value is about a 1,004,
I believe, in SI units.
So I have to confess, I'm a
little bit sloppy, that number
is so close to 10 that I very
often round it off to 10 when
I'm doing quick calculations.
And I've done that here
in my little example.
Let's say I've got air at sea
level that's at 10 degrees
Celsius and I move it up
in the atmosphere three
kilometers, 3,000 meters.
What temperature will
it be at when it
reaches that higher elevation?
Well, if I round that off to
10, it's cooling 10 degrees
for every kilometer that I lift
it, so it's going to cool
by 30 degrees Celsius,
approximately.
Please, I would ask you not
to do that rounding.
In your problem sets, let
it be 9.8, not 10.
But for the purposes of
illustration, it's going to
cool by approximately
30 degrees Celsius.
It starts at 10, so it's going
to be minus 20 Celsius when it
gets to 3 kilometers.
You can do that in Kelvins
as well, it will work
out the same way.
If it starts at--
let's see if it's 10 degrees
Celsius, that's going to be
283 Kelvins, and subtract 30
from that, it's going to be
253 Kelvins when it
gets up there.
So you might want to put both
the Celsius and the Kelvins in
your notes to be sure you're
clear on that question.
STUDENT: So that first one
there is it's shown as
expanded in that diagram?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I've drawn it that way to remind
you that the reason
it's cooled is because
it has expanded.
It moved into a region where
the pressure was less and
therefore, it naturally expanded
because of that
lowered pressure.
Question.
STUDENT: So it doesn't matter
the size of the air parcel?
PROFESSOR: No.
So it's so simple.
It doesn't matter the size of
the parcel, it's just that
elevation difference is
all that matters.
That tells you how much, on
a relative basis, it has
expanded, and therefore,
how many degrees
Celsius it has cooled.
Now remember I said this
is reversible.
If I take that parcel and move
it back down, it'll compress
back down to its original
volume, and it'll return to
its original temperature.
So it's a reversible process.
STUDENT: Are you assuming the
parcel was on the ground?
PROFESSOR: The question is
whether we're
assuming it was on the ground.
No, not necessarily.
This would happen, I could start
at any elevation and
move it to any other
elevation.
So this is independent of
where the ground was.
I just happened to give you an
example with the ground.
Just a three kilometer lifting,
no matter where you
started, would give you an
approximate 330 degrees
Celsius cooling.
Questions on that?
OK.
Now, we can begin to do some
calculations then of what
happens to air as you move it up
and down in the atmosphere.
Using these two concepts, the
measured lapse rate and the
adiabatic lapse rate.
So normally in the textbooks,
you'll see diagrams like this,
where the temperatures have
been put on the x-axis,
altitude's been put on the
y-axis, and some reference
lines are drawn on here,
where the slope,
given by capital gamma.
And then I've drawn in a black
curve, which represents the
actual lapse rate on the day,
under consideration.
Let's say we've launched a
balloon, measured temperature
as a function of height, and
I've plotted that up as that
black line.
Now, the question is what's
going to happen to an air
parcel as it's moved upwards
or downwards in
this kind of a situation.
If I take an air parcel from
this elevation and lift it,
it's going to cool.
It's going to cool moving along
the dashed blue curves,
because that's the adiabatic
lapse rate.
So this parcel, when I take it
out of its environment and
lift it a little ways, it's
going to move along like this
to its new elevation.
Its new temperature is going
to be there and the
temperature of its
new environment
is going to be there.
Here's the tricky part
of this argument.
When you take an air parcel and
lift it, it's cooling at
one rate, its environment is
changing at a different rate.
And we're interested in knowing,
after we lift it a
certain amount, what is its
temperature relative to the
environment?
It's new, the air that
it's now next to.
In this case, the parcel went to
that temperature, it moved
into cooler air above,
but that wasn't
such a great effect.
And actually, the parcel is
now colder than its new
environment.
Environment cooled, the parcel
cooled, the parcel cooled
more, so the parcel is now
cold, relative to its new
environment.
What's going to happen
to that parcel?
It's going to sink because
it's more dense than its
environment.
So I lifted it up there, it
looks around and says, oh my
lord, I am dense than
everything up
here, back down I go.
I don't belong here
in this crowd.
I've got to go back, I'm
negatively buoyant, I'm heavy,
I'm going to sink back.
You can repeat it.
You could push that parcel down
in the atmosphere, it'll
move to here.
There's a new temperature.
There is a new temperature
of its environment.
It got warmer, as
it went down.
The environment got warmer too,
but it got warmer faster.
Therefore, it's warmer than
its new environment.
It's now buoyant.
It's going to want to bob back
up to its original condition.
This is called a stable
atmosphere.
This term is very important,
this is called a stable
atmosphere because a parcel that
is lifted upwards wants
to sink back down, a parcel
that's pushed down wants to
bob back up.
And the atmosphere is usually in
this state, but not always.
I want to look at this second
example, here, which is again,
temperature plotted
versus altitude.
The same reference lines
have been drawn on
here for capital gamma.
But I put a different actual
lapse rate on that curve.
It's a lapse rate where
the temperature
increases with height.
This is an example
of an inversion.
If I take a parcel from here and
lift it, it gets colder.
I'm going to take it from that
elevation up to that elevation.
There's the parcel
temperature.
It's actually been moving into
warmer air, however.
So the new environment
is there.
So this is an extreme example
of stability.
This is a very stable
environment where the parcel
gets colder as you go up, the
environment gets warmer.
And so you develop these
restoring forces, this
tendency for the parcel to want
to quickly remove, go
back to where it was, are
amplified, in this case,
because of the inversion.
That's the reason why air cannot
mix effectively through
an inversion.
Because the air parcels want to
cool as they rise, and yet
there's warmer air aloft, the
two things add to each other,
making it virtually impossible
for air parcels to mix upwards
or downwards, for that matter.
The air tends to lay in stable
layers, stratified stable
layers with very little
turbulent mixing in a
situation like this.
Now the situation that I didn't
do, and you can fill in
your notes, do one last
case where now--
tilt this curve over so
it's flatter than
the reference curves.
Leave some space in your
notes for this.
Take that observed temperature,
the black line,
rotate it over until it's more
horizontal than the blue
reference lines.
And then repeat the argument.
What you're going to find there
is it if you look to
parcel, it suddenly becomes
buoyant relative to its
environment and it'll
continue to rise.
That's called an unstable
atmosphere.
Same thing would happen
if you pushed it down.
It would become negatively
buoyant and it would then drop
further, another illustration
that it's an unstable
atmosphere.
So this sort of thing will
have a big impact on how
materials mix around
in the atmosphere.
And as we will see next time,
it also has a big impact on
how clouds develop.
Next week, we're going to get
into the issue of water vapor
in the atmosphere,
how clouds form.
And then by Wednesday or so, how
precipitation forms in the
atmosphere.
And I think we'll call
it quits today.
But that will be the subject
for next week.